n
collective. Jacaudrey
Charbonneau.
- Des couleurs vives,
des récompenses.
C'est un jeu vidéo qui compte
plus de 250 millions d'a
de jeunes.
- Phil! Protège-moi.
- Ceaiains seraient même
devenus dépendantsvavavavavavav,
n'étaient pas du tout agressifs,
ne sacraient pas. Maintenant,
ils sacrent, ils font des coups
dans le mur...
Il y a plein d'autres histoires
qu'on a entendues.toilettes. Do,
ils jouent, puis...
s s s témoignages de la sorte,
cette avocate en a recueillis
des centaines depuis la demande.
Un juge de la Cour supérieure
vient de l'autoriser.
- Ce qu'on vient à leur
reprocher, c'est d'avoir
un produit nocif, sans en avoir
divulgué les risques
- Même si on peut lire dans
le jugement, qu'il manque encore
d'études sur la cyberdépendance,
le juge s'appuie sur une
comparaison
- "À titre analogique, l'effet
nocif du tabac n'a pas été
reconnu
au lendemain."
- Laféféférence entre
le cigarettier et le jeu vidéo,
n'est jamais bonne.
- Alors qu'il y côcôcôcôtés
positifs aux jeux vidéo,
tempère cette experte en
cyberdépen d d d d d d d d d d r
le rôle de l'industrie
pour ulèlèlèlème reconnu
par l'Organisation mondiale
de la santé depuis 2019.
subventionnée. Pas Epic Games,
mais au Québec, on subventionne
beaucoup l'industrie des jeuxpet
se poser la question : quelle
est leur part de responsabilité
et comment peuvent-ils aider?ids
cyberdépendants, c'est
justement la mission du centre
d'hébergement Le grand chemin,is
depuis quelques années.
Environ 3 % des jeunes
seraient atteints,
MARIE-JOSÉE MICHAUD, spécialiste
centres Le grand chemin
- Moi, à chaque semaine,
demandes d'aide de parents
qui vont m'interpeller pour
me dire : "Ça n'a plus de sens.i
se lance en bas d'une voiture
pendant qu'on va chez
maman qui n'a pas l'Internet.
- Bien qu'il soit gratuit,
le jeu "Fortnite
l'entremise de la monnaie
virtuel : le. . . . . L'autre
volet de l'action collective
vise donc à récupérer les sommes
dépensée C C C C C C C C C C C ,
Radio-Canada, Montréa